[موسيقى]
طبعا كلنا اتفرجنا او حضرنا كونسرت او
باند او حتى مغني ورا فرقه موسيقيه كلنا
طبعا بنستمتع قوي بالموسيقى وبنعيش معاها
وبننسى الوقت فيها على ايام اهالينا مثلا
كانت حفلات ام كلثوم الميوزك بتبدا فيها
وتشتغل بالساعات قبل ما هي تبدا اصلا
تتكلم وتطلع تغني والاود انس كلهم قاعدين
بيسمعوا ومبسوطين قوي بده ومستمتعين قوي
بده حد فكر في الكواليس ورا انه يطلع عمل
رائع زي ده يخاطب الناس كلها ويخلي الناس
كلها قاعده مبسوطه اكيد بغض النظر عن تعب
الناس وموهبتها في العسف خلينا نف فكر
اكتر في كواليس الاله اللي بتطلع على
الستيج وتخلي الناس كلها
مستمتعه طبعا الالات زمان كانت كلها
بتتعمل هاند ميد من
الخشب ما كانش في ميكنه يمكن دلوقتي دخل
شويه شويه ميكنه في نوع من انواع الالات
بس في الات تانيه محافظه على شكلها انه بس
بيتعمل هاند ميد طب ايه رايكم في اللي
بيعمل عود هاند ميد من بلوكه خشب يقدر
يطلع عود تفتكروا ممكن يكون سنه قد ايه و
ممكن يكون مثلا قدي يكون اكبر مني شويه
خليني اوري اقول لكم اللي في الصوره
دلوقتي
هو انا انا وانا عندي ثمان سنين وانا بصنع
اول عود ل وتعالوا احكي لكم القصه اللي
ورا ان انا اعمل عود لوحدي انا اتربيت في
عائله بابايا وجدي صناع عود على اعلى
مستوى فبدا ان انا زي اي طفل متشوق اشوف
الحياه ف بابا بياخدني معاه الورشه روح
اتفرج على العمال ازاي بيشتغلوا اسمع
الناس اللي بتعزف اقعد العب مع بابا العب
مع فريق
العمل لحد ما واحده واحده ب بدا يغين انه
يديني تاسك صغيره قوي ويقوللي اعملها انا
زي ادق مسمار زي حاجات بسيطه جدا
ماذنش وياخدها الاقيه بيكمل عليها وبيحط
في العود اللي بيروح لفنان او بيروح لعازف
كبير فبدا واحده واحده احس انه انا اقدر
اعمل حاجه انا بشارك حتى لو بحاجه صغيره
في ال الكبير ده فبدا بابا
يشوفني متحمس قوي لده فاثر ان انا وانا
عندي ثمان سنين ان هو يعلمني ازاي اعمل
عود لوحدي من الاول للاخر وامشي في كل
البروسيز اللي في صناعه العود وامشي واحده
واحده اخد فكره عنها واتعلم لحد ما عملت
اول عود ل وانا عندي ممان سنين طبعا ايده
كانت معايا لان المعدات ثقيله وفي حاجات
كتير مش طفل صغير يقدر يمسكها ويتعامل
معاها بس بمساعدته قدرت اني اطلع باول عود
ليا وانا عندي ممان سنين فضلت كده وفضل
جوايا الشغف وبابا شايف ان انا حابب
الموضوع ده فبدا انه يحس انه عايز ينقلني
لفكره ان انا اكون صانع بروفيشنال مش بس
انا باجي بلعب فبدا يقوللي عشان تكون
بروفيشنال انت محتاج تمسك بروسيس بروسيس
تتقنها وتفضل شغال فيها كتير قوي بروسيس
زي ايه زي مثلا من اول ما بيجي بلوكه
الخشب ازاي بنشق ونقطعها نطلع منها اضلع
متساويه ازاي على النار على قالب على شكل
عود عشان يطلع معانا شكل العود ازاي بنقفل
القصعه وبعدين ننضفها ونوصل الدلو لل
التخانه اللي احنا عايزينها ازاي بنعمل وش
العود
وبنفتكر اللي احنا عايزينه نوصله التخان
اللي احنا عايزينها نرص عليه حاجه اسمها
الدوائي اس في ظهر الوش بتاع العود ده
عشان نخلص البروسيس دي نبدا نعمل الرقبه
بتاعه العود وازاي بنخلص ازاي بنركبها في
الاصعب زاويه ميل معينه عشان تريح العازف
ازاي بنعمل بانجا اللي هو يعتبر بيت
المفاتيح بتاع العود اللي بيمسك
الاوتار وفضلت في بروسيس ورا التانيه وانا
في السنين الكتيره دي بابا بياخدني معاه
الفنانين كبيره وملحنين كبيره في العالم
العربي كله وبلاقي في وشهم فرحه غريبه
بالعود اللي بابا بيديه لهم هم مقدرين قوي
اللي هو عمله ومبسوطين قوي بيه ويبدا
كلماتهم بانه شكرا انك بتعمل لنا حاجه
خلينا عارفين نعبر عن احساسنا ومشاعرنا
للاخر بسببك انت وبداوا مع الوقت يشجعوني
انه يلا الجد عن انت وتبدا تعمل انت عود
من الالف للياء لوحدك من غير مساعده باباك
وصلت لسن 20 سنه وحسيت ان انا اقدر دلوقتي
ان انا اعمل الحاجه دي لوحدي وابدا اعمل
انا من الالف للياء لوحدي فبدات اعمل
اعواد واديها للفنانين اللي كانوا بيشجعو
واعرضها عليهم وياخدوا مني اعواد ده انا
برض باسمي ويطلعوا بيها في حفلات ويطلعوا
بيها في الاستوديو ويسجلوا بيها حاجات
واحده واحده ما بقتش فاهم ايه اللي مخلي
بابا متميز ما هو في 3000 صانع او 4000
صانع في مصر بس غير باقي الدول العربيه زي
لبنان وسوريا والعراق
ايران تركيا فيها صناع بالهبل وكتير جدا
ايه اللي مخلي بابا وسطهم هو اللي متميز و
بيتكرم في البلاد على انه احسن صانع لقيت
ان بابا ما اخدش من جده مسلمات وماشي
عليها ومش بيحاول يطور فيها لقيت ان بابا
درس واخد دراسات على اله اسمها اللوت اله
غربيه ليها 14 شكل شكل منهم يشبه العود
جدا فبدا يشوف ايه الدراسات اللي اتعملت
عليه فطلع بمعادلات بين العرض والعمق
والطول خلي فيه بالانس بالصوت واخد دراسات
تانيه انه يرتب الدوائي اللي بتتحط في ظهر
العود بطريقه معينه عشان يتحكم في صوت
العود من قبل ما يطلع ان كان حاد للناس
اللي بتحب تلعب تكنيك او ان كان صوته شرقي
شبهنا شويه شبه موسيقه ام كلثوم فنقدر
نتحكم في كل حاجه في العود من قبل ما
العود
يخلص بدات اشوفه كمان عنده باشن قوي ناحيه
ده كل شويه عايز يطلع افكار جديده في
الديزاين كل شويه بيطلع حاجات جديده
يعملها يستخدم خامات جديده ويدخلها زي
اصداف باشكالها كلها زي عضم الجمل زي ظهر
السلحفه و فعلا في عواد معموله في ظهر
السلحفه بناخد منها قشره ونركبه جنب بعض
والعود بيطلع بظهر السلحفه وازاي التتال
الطبيعيه دي مش بتاثر على الصوت بتنقله
كمان لنقله تانيه فبدات احس ان هو ده البا
اللي انا لازم اخده ان انا مش بس اكون
بستلم من بابايا ومش بطور في ده لان انا
حابب ده فانا هكمل فيه واديله اهتمام بان
انا اكبره اكتر واطور اكتر انا بدرس هندسه
كمبيوتر اللي يعرف اي بروجرامر او هو نفسه
بروجرامر هيبقى عارف ان انت بتتعلم في
الكورس وفي
الجامعات لاين وبي قوي ب جدا بعدين يطلب
منك بروجكت كبيره جدا فانت بتحتاج انت طول
الوقت تقعد تدور انت وتشوف انت وتوصل
للمعلومه اولا كود اللي هيفيدك فده علمني
ان انا اقدر شويه ان انا اكون
بدور على التست ري معموله على اشكال جديده
او صنا هد ميد عالم ازاي بيعملوا ديزاينز
مختلفه ازاي نقدر نطبقها بطريقه شرقيه على
العود ازاي نقدر نحط اخشاب مختلفه تطلع
اصوات مختلفه
ا بعد القصه دي اللي عاييز اقوله انه بابا
اللي ميزه ان هو اختار ده وهو بيحبه لان
هو اتخرج من بكالوريوس تجاره وكان معاه
شهاده ويقدر ان يتوظف بيها ويعيش بطريقه
ستيبل حتى بالرغم انه العود ساعتها ما
كانش مشهور قوي عند بابا وما كانش بيجيب
العائد المادي اللي يعيشه مرتاح هو اختار
ده ومشي فيه لان هو روحه فيه واحبه جدا
اللي انا بقول انا برض في هندسه قدام
الكارير مفتوح قوي لو سالتوا اي حد
هيقولكم هندسه كمبيوتر ده هو المستقبل ده
هي الفلوس ده هي كل حاجه بس انا بقول ان
انا بختار ده لان انا بحبه لان انا عشت
وضقت فييه حاجه مختلفه ولان انا بختار
ولان انا بحب ده فانا هعرف اديله وقت
اديله اهتمام واتقنه اكتر اللي انا عايز
اقوله انه مش الهدف نكون بنعمل حاجه
مختلفه وخلاص الفكره ان انت تكون بتتبع
الحاجه اللي انت بتحبها فهتكون مختلف فيها
شكرا
لوقتكم